we've known for a while that the most  likely outcome in November is that  Democrats keep the Senate but lose the  house and I think we've come to terms  with that but the really crazy thing the  really scary thing is that some of the  nuttiest of the Republican candidates  that are running actually have a shot at  winning Kerry Lake from Arizona most  recently is up about a point she's  Bonkers Blake Masters in Arizona for  Senate running against Mark Kelly  he's not out of it he's only down a few  points even Herschel Walker in Georgia  who can barely explain his position on  any issue and pulled out a fake badge  during a recent debate I am with minute  police officers  he's not out of it it is utterly  dystopian